قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت 65 غاره واطلقت اربعه
وثمانين مقذوفا من رجمات الصواريخ باتجاه
مواقع اوكرانيه ومناطق سكنيه خلال الساعات
24 الماضيه ما ادى الى سقوط ضحايا مدنيين
وتدمير بنى تحتيه في مناطق عده واضافت
الهيئه ان الطيران الاوكراني نفذت تسع
غارات على المواقع الروسيه واسقط مروحيه
روسيه وخمسه مسيرات وطائرتين استطلاع دون
طيار واكدت ان قوتها صدت هجمات روسيه في
اتجاه كوبيانس والايمان
كما اشار بيان الهيئه الى وقوع 26 اشتباكا
على طول خط الجبهه
في المقابل اعلن المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب
الروسيه شن غارتين جويتين على قوات
اوكرانيه ومعدات وحدات اللواء الميكانيكي
الاوكراني 14
واضاف ان قواته وجه الضربات على مواقع
وحدات اللواء الميكانيكي 32 في منطقه
ستيلما هوفكا الاوكرانيه في مدن
كوتشيروفكا
وبثلوثكا في اتجاهي كوبينس